we're now
on youtube yeah we're down live chair
yeah thank you tom
good morning everybody i'd like to
welcome you all to this virtual meeting
of the plans committee of the
3rd of december i'll just go through
through some basic rules for the meeting
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones except mine
please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked by me to speak
residents who want to exercise exercise
this right have been asked to register
in advance
and also have had the option of sending
the statement to us which will be read
by an officer
or have been sent a link to temporarily
join the meeting to speak in person
once they've finished speaking there
will be removed as a petition
participant in the meeting and can be
written this on youtube
we have one two three four five six so
eight people to speak this morning
or sent in statements to indicate to me
that you would like to speak or propose
a second emotion
please please press the raise the hand
symbol
in the participants menu on your screen
i think everybody's got used to that by
now
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they are pressed
and i'll deal with them in order giving
the appropriate officer
or counsellor the opportunity to answer
in between where necessary i will also
return to the counsellor
to check that they're happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote and names will be read out
in alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly
when your name is read out unmuting and
muting your microphone
as necessary please remember that to
ensure full transparency
with the democratic process this meeting
is being live streamed
on the council's youtube channel
i ask you all to be patient particularly
with me
during this meeting and to understand
that processes
and advice may take longer than usual we
do have now and again glitches with
broadband connections
throughout the district and and also
sometimes
with officers giving their presentation
so do bear bear with us
i will now ask each committee member to
introduce themselves
and then after committee members if the
officers present
would introduce themselves please i'll
start with myself
i'm councillor chris leather and i
represent northern ward
all right
who wants to go well because
watson and i represent broadleaf
richard sorry i'm council richard bowden
i represent hartman ward
sorry cheshire kirsty do you want to
read a role call that would be the best
way
all right tom thank you yeah yeah
yes certainly um councillor balton's
been so councillor brown yes good
morning i represent great chorington
thank you councillor christie
good morning my name is peter christie i
represent biddeford north
councillor craigie uh good morning
my name's uh ruth craigie and i
represent biddeford east
councillor leather's been councillor
lock good morning my name is rosalie
lock and i represent two rivers and
three malls
councillor mcgoff good morning my name
is dermot mcgolf and i represent
biddeford north
councillor watson has been councillor
weissman
hello i'm richard wiseman i represent
the shebia and langtry ward
that's that's a full house i think isn't
it kirsty
yeah yes that's right chair thank you
right item one on the agenda is
apologies well i don't think there are
any apologies because we've got
a full compliment again thank you for
that
sorry before we go there
yeah the officers were going to
introduce themselves yeah
good morning i'm stacey dorey i'm head
of legal and governance for torridge
district council
uh good morning members good morning
members of public my name's sean
harrington i'm planning manager at
torres district council
good morning members members of the
public i'm helen smith and i
am development management team leader
here at toronto district council
good morning members good morning
members of the general public my name is
tracy blackmore i'm a principal planner
at
um here at torres district council
good morning members and good morning
men's members of the public i'm angelo
masos a planning officer
thank you i think that's everybody
knowing that
yeah that's all the officers present
right thank you okay we'll move on then
to item two on the agenda which
is minutes of the last meeting we held
which are on pages five and it's the
minutes of the meeting with the first
fifth of november pages five to thirteen
if somebody i'd like to propose those
minutes
councillor watson proposing the net
council lock
i will second the minutes thank you
council a lot
so it's been proposed by councillor
watson secondly by council a lot that we
accept
those minutes as a correct record
trustee could you please take the votes
on those
thank you chair councillor balton uh for
councillor brown for
councillor christie for councillor
craigie
for councillor leather or
counselor lock or counselor mcgoff
or councillor watson or
councillor wiseman or that's unanimous
chair
thank you kirsten item three on the
agenda is
declarations of interest members with
interest to declare should refer to the
agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest
when the item is being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who've
considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered
the application applications separately
on the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned
who consider the application afresh
because it's at this meeting where we
have all the information
right up to the last minute concerning
the application
item four is agreement of the agenda
between parts one and two
or there is no part two on the agenda
item five is urgent matters i have no
urgent matters to bring up
sean harrington sean i don't know
whether you have any urgent matter you
want to bring forward
uh no chair thank you thank you item six
is future site visits
we don't know of any currently but no
doubt there will be some
for the january meeting and item seven
is
public participation
we've got as i said at the start we've
got eight eight to speak to
today
we've had four to speak to the
south street uh or sydney house car park
south street
car park mill street torrington um
and i'll i'll give the names as we get
to them
and then for the old telephone exchange
we've got four to speak to that one as
well
the order of speakers as follows the
planning officer will give their
presentation of the application
and then any town or parish council
representative who wishes to speak for
or for or against the application
they have three minutes and then up to
two
members of the public who wish to speak
against the application
they have three minutes each and then we
have two public
speakers in support of the application
and they have three minutes each
and the final speakers is any
territories council member from the ward
in which the application falls and
there's no time limit
for their contribution
okay we'll move on then eight on the
agenda is planning applications
the information recommendations and
advice
contained in the reports are correct at
the date of preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided
in writing or orally orally at the
committee meeting
and so we move on into 80 which is our
first application this morning
on pages 14 to 46
and it's the sydney house south street
car park application
and our officer helen smith will present
this
application thank you helen
thank you chair and yes this this
application
reference one forward slash zero zero
seven zero forward slash 2018
out proposes the erection of nine
dwellings
together with associated landscaping and
in infrastructure at um
land adjacent to south street car park
also known as sydney house
car park mill street great torrington
um it is made in outline however
matters of access scale and
layout are all before members for
determination today
with appearance and landscaping for a
later determination as part of a reserve
matters application
i'm sure members will be aware that this
was originally due to be considered at
our august committee
however due to a late consultation
response from historic england
it was pulled from that committee and
subsequent
detailed discussions have taken place
with historic england
to the extent that we're now able to
bring this application back before you
um just to confirm it is brought before
committee due to the
application site involving land that is
within tourist district council's
ownership
before i run through the full
presentation i just want to give some
updates
firstly in terms of representations that
have been received
since publication of the committee
report on the 23rd of november
we have received three further letters
of representation
one of those is from an m clerk and a
rollinson they have submitted a letter
of objection raising concerns over any
potential vehicular access
onto mill street um
due to concerns they would have over
safety amenity
issues with such a vehicular access
also they raised concern over the
prominence of the site
and the the fear that the development
would be an eyesore
and also harm to wildlife we have also
received a further letter from
a neighbor mr matt whitaker
this letter provided was provided on the
27th
this um representation 27th of november
provided additional details on the um
anticipated impacts on mr whitaker's
solar panels
the agenda report does make reference to
an
initial financial sum that mr whittaker
had indicated in an earlier
representation and it's indicated it's
been 200
000 pounds mr whitaker has updated this
now
to include reference to
potential increases in electricity
prices
he makes reference to the loss of the
initial cost
and energy efficient electric heaters
the additional energy cost that he
that would be imposed from him due to
the
lower energy that would be generated
from the panels loss of feed in tariff
and he attributes all of those to a
likely 10 reduction in turnover for his
business which operates from
number three mill street so the total
figure
as indicated by mr whitaker on the 27th
of november
is 210 460
pounds 24 pence so just to update on
that
and members are aware of a further
letter we received on behalf of mr
whitaker from his solicitor
um late yesterday afternoon this was
circulated to members so i don't propose
to read through it
however i will just summarize the four
key points that are raised
um firstly there is a suggestion that
it's not appropriate for this
application to be considered an outline
due to the need to properly assess
heritage impacts
of of the proposal and this matter is
dealt with in the agenda report
so we can obviously discuss that later
the second point is a suggestion that
there hasn't been enough time
for potential objectives to consider all
of the information that is before
members today
the only the only material that has been
received
since the publication of the agenda
report
is the independent overshadowing
assessment which members were aware
would
would
be um following after publication of
that report
that assessment has been made available
on our website for anybody to view
and that assessment it's important to
note that was
commissioned by the council given that
we've had
sort of differing views put forward in
terms of the impact of the development
on
the solar panels it was considered
important to
to get an independent view on that the
third point rage
raised um again suggests there's an
inaccuracy both in
the applicant's light assessment and the
independent consultants
overshadowing study suggesting that the
position as in the sighting
of mr whitaker's solar panels is
incorrect
previous concerns have been raised over
the level that the
the panels were set and the the
applicant's agent did
correct this but he is now suggesting
that his panels are a meter
closer to the site he's suggesting it's
a nine meter
distance between the panels and the
development boundary
and finally there is um
a question as to whether the the council
in in its decision-making powers should
be applying the tilted balance in light
of the burwood decision
and as i said members have seen this
this letter and hopefully had a chance
to read it
and i'd be very happy to answer any
specific questions that arise out of its
content
after my presentation and when you're
debating the application
the next update is on the independent
overshadowing study
members were informed that this was
imminent when
we held the virtual site visit um as i
said this was
commissioned to specifically assist
officers
and the council in assessing the impact
of
the development on the solar panels
and as members are aware and as set out
in the
delega in the offices report um
the impact on the panels is a material
planning consideration
in light of the legal judgment that's
referred to so
the consultant who has prepared this
independent study
is also attending the meeting so he will
be available to answer any specific
questions
finally a further condition is
recommended
in addition to the conditions set out in
your agenda report
the the application seeks to set layout
and within that layout there is a
communal area area of open space
identified
as there is no legal agreement that will
be secured as part of this application
it is recommended that
the following condition is provided
included on any
should members be minded to approve it
which will seek to
secure a management and maintenance
scheme for the open space
as well as it's um it's phasing within
this
within the eventual development
so now moving on to the presentation
this is the submitted site can i just
ask a question here i have raised my
hand
yeah counselor christy i did see your
hand up i was going to bring you in to
comment
the minute that helen finished giving
her a presentation
i think that let helen give a
presentation and then you can come right
in then and ask
could i have some guidance from the
planning uh department because
on page 24 of our agenda today historic
england say
the application is neither entirely
outlined nor a full application
um can i have some explanation of that
because in our agenda it says it's an
outline
is it outline or have historic england
got it wrong
yeah chair i'm happy to respond on that
point now the
the extract from the historic england
response that council christie is
referring to is actually their first
response in respect of the
original scheme their their second
response is the one that's more
pertinent in terms of what is before
members today
historic england did raise concerns over
the nature of
the previous proposal and and
in fact they actually suggested less
detail should be provided
however further to very detailed
discussions with historic england
the level of detail for this outlying
application which does include layout
and scale
and access is historic england are
satisfied with that
so it is the later consultation response
that that does relate to this current
proposal
and i think that extract was from an
earlier response okay
chair are you happy for me too thanks
helen thanks for that explanation
okay chair i've had my hand raised for
quite a while i need to declare interest
please
well i'm sorry councillor brown but i
have not seen your hair depend upon
it's on my screen but sorry i need to
declare interest
as being jewel hatted a member of great
toronton town council
thank you councillor brown thanks for
that
okay thank you chair so this is the the
site application
it is um 0.47 hectares
in in sight area as you can see it's
within the built form of great
torrington
it's a rectangular in shape it's the
site is
located immediately to the west of the
car park
across which access would be achieved as
can be seen
and it's important to note that the red
line does not connect in any way to mill
street which is
further to the west um i'm sure members
will have noted that a number of
concerns have been raised over potential
vehicular access onto mill street
however that clearly isn't provided for
as part of this application
this just shows an aerial photo in the
wider context of great turrington
so that members can appreciate how the
application site sits within the wider
built form
of the settlement just coming in more
closely to the site now
it's currently redundant and disused
with its most recent use being as a
market garden
it's currently very overgrown with
vegetation
and members will recall that previously
um they
a previous committee approved an
application for a waitrose superstore
on this site so it is that same that
same site
the site slopes gently from north to
south
to the north you can see the rear
gardens of the dwellings on mill street
mill street itself is set at quite a
higher level
to the south you can see the very
northern edge of
the great torrington commons which also
is a county wildlife site
to the west um the large dwelling to the
sort of southwest
corner is kington house which is a grade
two listed property
and the the dwellings immediately to the
north of cayton house and to the west of
the application site
are known as cainton court and they are
sort of more modern
architectural style um at the west at
the eastern side of the car park
to the immediate east of where all the
cars are parked you can see that there
is the tourism information
center the museum and the 1646
attraction
so just looking at the existing survey
plan as consistent with the previous
aerial image
you can see that the main marked up area
of the car park is on the eastern
side with the the intervening area
between the application
site and that marked up area not being
formally
marked for car parking there are some
coach parking spaces
right down at the end of the car park
adjacent to the development site
however they would be recited to
accommodate the development
this is an extract again from the
north devon torridge local plan
proposals map the site is outlined in
blue
on here um so not to confuse that with
the the normal red that you see
however the the red line with the
triangles in is the conservation area
um as you can see roughly a third the
eastern third of the site is within the
great torrington conservation area
the site also sits within the
development boundary which abuts it
immediately to the south
and it is immediately adjacent to the
great torrington town centre which is
identified in purple
and this is an extract from historic
england's
mapping system which identifies listed
buildings
within proximity to the site kington
house which
i've already mentioned is probably the
main list of building that holds the
closest and strongest relationship with
the site
there are however additional listed
buildings most notably
numbers one three and five mill street
which are immediately to the north
of the site i will just run through some
photos now
um firstly starting with some long-range
views of the site
this photos taken from the car park at
rhs rosemoor
um i think the the point to always look
for in these long range views is the
the white facade of um cayton house
which you can see centrally located
um the the application site as as you've
seen from the
application plans is immediately to the
east
of canton house so you can also note the
trees
that also the maturities that that stand
along that
that frontage as well this is from
mary's clothes down in teddy port and
you can see
cainton house sort of right on the
eastern end of the built form
the application site would sit in
between the
there's a large tree which sits to the
front of canton house you can see
there's a gap
there that is the application site this
this is a photo taken in the summer
a similar position just shows the the
visual impact in winter when there's
obviously less tree coverage
this is now an image taken from the road
leading out of teddy port
so beyond saint mary's close you can see
the the grand presence of cainton house
the large trees immediately associated
with cainton house and then there's the
gap
which would be the site the mature trees
i think you can just make out sort of
copper beech tree
and then two sort of more significant
trees immediately to the east of it
those trees are proposed to be retained
as part of the development as
as will be seen on the proposed layout
later
that's that same roughly the same expert
in winter
and again that's just further along the
road so it just shows that
that that relationship of the site with
the existing built form
this is a photo taken just from the the
path
at the most northern part of the commons
the large tree immediately
in front of us is the tree that stands
to the front of cainton house
the site is immediately on our right
here you'll see that there is a drop in
levels
and there is established vegetation and
trees
so this is looking at a westerly
direction this is looking in the
easterly direction so the site will sit
within back from this gap
now just looking in from the car park so
this
um shows the view of the site from
within the south street sydney house car
park
and just beyond um it's important to
know the
properties on mill street which you can
see on the right so there is that
that built form that does sit much
higher than the application
site and this would also be the route
that
the future residents should it be
approved and developed would take to the
site
this is the eastern side of the car park
um
this shows where sort of 1646 in the
tourist information area
is and it's characterized by stone
walling render
slate roofing um so it's just helpful to
show that because we do have some
indicative images
as to how how the development on this
application site
could look just within the application
site now this is the southern boundary
you can see sort of teddy port beyond
there
the nature of the trees on the frontage
canton house can be seen the
hipped side roof of it just beyond
this is now looking across the western
boundary of the site where you can see
canet in the house and cainton court
and then some of the properties on mill
street
and again this is the the western
boundary of the site
the um the property on cayton court
which you can see in the middle here
with the two
the two bedroom windows this is
specifically referred to within the
amenity section of the report
so just to highlight that that is the
dwelling with the two-bedroom windows
that would look onto the site that
that is being referred to
so then as we move around to look at the
north part of the site
you can see the properties of mill
street again more clearly and how they
are at a raised level
to the application site the tree
immediately here on the left is a tree
that's due to be retained it is within
the application
site and also importantly you can see
the positioning of the solar panels so
the the objective mr whitaker who lives
at three
mill street and operates his business
from three mill street
these are the panels in question um
which are present in his lower
his lower garden and have been subject
to a number of representations
i think members should know clearly at
the moment there is no boundary
there's a very low wall i think it's
about sort of three
three stone of that wall there is no
other boundary between
that garden and the application site as
things are at the moment
there are now a few photos from within
mr whitaker's garden who
um he kindly agreed to let me visit the
site so i could appreciate its
relationship with the application site
this photo
shows the positioning of the solar array
within that lower garden its proximity
to the rear wall
and the way in which it is attached to
the ground
and it then pans around so you can see
the solar panels and that relationship
with the application site and the nature
of that boundary
you can also appreciate the nature of
existing vegetation along
other bound that certainly that boundary
immediately adjoining
um this garden of three mill street
and then this is just looking back from
the application site
and just so that members can appreciate
the panels
how they sit in relation to the ground
and their positioning again
within the site finally just to
to show some images of the point of
access this is the main access into the
car park so
future residents will be utilizing this
access and certainly not any access onto
mill street
and this is again looking from the road
so you would turn
right here into the car park
and again this is the road that links
out back to join the main highway
network
just running through the scheme now um
this is the revised layout that is
before members for determination
so the sighting of the dwellings is for
consideration this this layout
has been developed over the last few
months
um in close discussion extensive
discussion with historic england
the council's conservation area
conservation officers sorry
myself and um to the applicant and agent
you can see that now it's a roughly sort
of horseshoe shape
c-shaped form of development with a
central courtyard
which would provide parking the
dwellings would be arranged around the
western northern and eastern
parts of the site with the southern
section being
left open for private gardens associated
with plots one and two
and a communal area of open space
provided centrally within the site
um 14 car parking spaces would be
provided within
the courtyard and then plots one and two
are shown as having an
attached garaging each which would
provide two car parking spaces
so there would be a total of eight of
two spaces per unit
across the site and the trees to be
retained on site you will see at the
northern end
we did see the tree in the photo and i
was showing the solar panels
so there's a tree at the rear and also
three
significant mature trees that are shown
on the southern end which would form
sort of the backdrop to the garden to
plot one these are all shown to be
retained
the floor area for each dwelling is
identified
within each plot so in setting scale
we are essentially setting a footprint
but also a maximum floor space
for the dwellings and these floor spaces
range from 100 square meters to 160
square meters
until the final design is confirmed
um it's not possible to say what the
bedroom
sizes would be but you know for to give
members an indication that would be a
mix of three and four bedroom units
so moving on scale is also for
determination
today and this section drawing
showing a southern street section and an
eastern street section
for each of the blocks each of the
dwellings there is a finished floor
level
and finished ridge height so the final
built form has to come forward within
those parameters
the finished floor levels are are
consistent and as one would expect
having had a look at the topographical
survey
it certainly doesn't involve a raising
of land um
it's it's in this certainly in the
southern street section you can
appreciate the relationship of the
development with kaneton house which is
set at a lower level
but also the relationship of the
application proposal with the
the physical built form to the rear on
mill street so the black outline
shows actually that there is a higher
built form behind the site
um there's also a mater an indicative
material palette shown which shows
render stone natural slate and still
consistent with the image i showed at
the eastern end of the car park
however confirmation of materials and
external appearances for the
reserve matters stage in terms of
heights of the dwellings
they range from roughly 7.6 meters to
8.4 meters
across the site um that's something that
was picked up
from historic england the desirability
for arranging ridge heights so that
the development can sit better in
context with that
that varied ridge height you can see the
existing development
behind and then this
is a sectional view there's an internal
eastern elevation street scene which
confirms the finished floor levels and
ridge heights for
the plots that weren't identified again
you can see the relationship with the
retained trees
the the sections through the valley show
the development again in the context of
the existing development so you can
appreciate how it sits with the existing
built form
i'm now going to show the proposed
layout in the context of the layout that
was approved for the waitrose scheme
um i i it's important to point out as
well that the waitrose application
for some reason hasn't pulled across to
show up in the planning history but it
is
very much part of the planning history
um it was an application for a food
waitrose food store which was approved
in june 2015 by committee
it has since expired so it would have
expired in june
2018. however it's important just to see
that context
and certainly for members who were on
committee at that time to understand how
this scheme relates
to that built footprint which was
previously um
considered acceptable in terms of a
difference in footprint the waitrose
scheme
was 1970 square meters
this residential scheme is 1240 square
meters so just to appreciate that but
you can see the built form
of the waitrose application came
significantly further forward
than than what is proposed now
similarly this shows the red
sort of sectional outline of the
approved
waitrose store and and how that relates
in built form to what's proposed now in
terms of sort of heights and massing
okay so um hopefully members will have
had a chance to review the independent
overshadow
study um prepared by carbon green
consulting
mr blackburn from the consultancy
is here today so he will be able to
answer any questions later
however i thought it would be helpful
just to include some of the
the modeled images within the
presentation
um so carbon green consulting have
modeled the development
against the pv panels um
to show the impact of overshadowing
arising from the development
so i'll just show a series of images now
which show the
existing unproposed positions in
march june and december so you can see
from the position
in march that um
the panels are shown in orange that
actually there is no
change in impact at that time of year
the overshadowing that can be seen
at five o'clock so the bottom images is
actually from the tree
that is that is to be retained on site
and it is not from the development
itself we move on to june
um when the sun is obviously at its
highest there there is no impact
at all on the development game you can
see the panels would still
enjoy that that same amount of direct
sunlight
moving on to december you can now see
that there will be
an impact from the development on on the
panels and there will be a degree of
overshadowing
this is most pronounced at three o'clock
you can see that they would be
completely
overshadowed by the development proposal
and to an extent that would also be over
overshadowing at midday and at 9am
the the overshadowing assessment
hopefully provides
um this graph which shows in blue the
existing pv
generation in megawatt hours against in
orange what the proposed
development impact would be on that on
that pv
generation and you can see the most
notable impacts
consistent with the image i just showed
is is december
but also january and february there
would be impacts as well
october and november very marginal
impacts but
but an impact nonetheless the rest of
the rest of the year there wouldn't be
an impact um and these are just the
figures that confirm that
it's probably easiest just to look at
the total which shows
um the existing position being 4.0195
against the impact of the development
being 3.893
so that shows that difference the
conclusions
of the overshadowing study in
in order to put sort of a financial
impact on that
indicates that that would equate to an
annual loss of 18 pounds 46 in terms of
the need to to buy more electricity off
the grid
that's at current electricity prices so
over a 20-year lifespan of the panels
that would be 369 pounds 38 pence in
terms of an impact
so finally just moving on to the
material considerations
the are all dealt with in detail in the
report
the principle of development is
considered acceptable the site is in the
development boundary it's a sustainable
location
and it's not allocated for any other
purpose design and impact on character
and heritage impacts it's
probably worth sort of summarizing those
together significant efforts have been
made by the applicant
and very productive discussions have
taken place with historic england
to reach this position um
to a point where there is considered to
be very limited harm
that can be associated with this
development
it's worth sort of probably drawing
specifically referring to some of
historic england's comments that
this revised scheme reduces visibility
of the development in long views into
torrington
and provides a better variety of depths
to break up the scheme visually
increases opportunities to minimize
impacts and harm
to the historic environment historic
england acknowledge that they can
control
we as an authority but also with their
impact and control the external
appearance at reserve matters stage
and also as layout is now for
consideration
and it significantly reduces the
potential for any harm
the outline nature of the application is
of much less concern
and consequently historic england have
indicated they don't need to be involved
any further
and are happy for it to be determined by
the authority they do refer
us to section 72 the 1990 act which
requires local planning authorities to
pay special attention to the
desirability of preserving or enhancing
the character or appearance of
conservation areas um
the historic impact assessment that's
been submitted
together with the comments of historic
england um you know
lead convincing case to be put that
there is very limited harm
arising out of this development um yes
of course there is a further stage to go
which will look at the detail
of the elevations but can be controlled
and
measures are recommended such as
agreeing a design code
to ensure that a high quality quality
design comes forward so whilst yes the
delegated report indicates there would
be harm
it is seen to be negligible very minimal
harm this is consistent with the
conclusions of the submitted historic
impact assessment
amenity the report goes into quite a lot
of detail on amenity
certainly reserve matter stage would be
when positioning of windows would be
considered
but officers are satisfied that there
would be no significant
harm in terms of overbearing impacts
highways no objections from devon county
council
drainage a condition is recommended but
there's no objections to
there being suitable solutions ecology
um a series of reports have been carried
out
there are protected species on site most
notably reptiles and a mitigation
strategy will be required
however conditions recommended to secure
all of those message methods
as well as enhancements the impact on
the solar installation i have already
touched on that but shouldn't
emphasize again that this is a material
consideration and the impact has been
certainly in terms of our independent
assessment doesn't identify the impact
as being
very minimal and so it is for the
decision taker to apply how much weight
they would put to that impact in the
planning balance
planning obligations and viability the
application does generate a need for
relatively small contributions towards
education and open space
however viability assessment has been
submitted which confirms that that
is is not a viable proposition and
finally the planning balance
um which is set out in detail it is not
considered that the
the minimal harm now identified and
associated with this
this scheme outweighs the benefits that
have been identified
and consequently the recommendation is
one of approval
right well thanks very much uh helen for
that very
comprehensive report and presentation of
that application
we've got i just asked councillor brown
there's a cross against your name is
that what you
is that the symbol that you're using
when you want to speak
councillor brown can you just commute
yourself a minute and answer please
yeah i just got a problem chair with my
mute and unmute
oh all right and the croc the cross that
you're showing there is that when you
want to speak
yes ah that's why i've not seen your
blue hand then
okay thank you okay thanks councillor
right well we've got uh four people have
registered to speak to this application
and the first one to speak is uh matt
whitaker
speaking against um and we've heard
that he is the chap who's got the solar
panels in his back garden
so if you were there matt whitaker
you'll have
three minutes to be able to present your
case
when when you when you're alive are you
there
yes um i believe i am okay thank you if
you'd like to start then please
okay um i wish to talk to you today
about the harm to my household from this
proposal
due to the shading on my solar panel
array
but i don't have the time to do that i
could tell you
how i understand that the independent
study on the negative impact
on the solar array was flawed because it
seems they put my array in the wrong
place
and also the effect of any occupants
planting trees
in their gardens was not addressed in
this um
this document either i i could mention
to the council
that they that they assist households to
be more energy efficient
but they seem to think it's acceptable
on this occasion to take it away from my
household
i would instead like to talk about the
hypocrisy
of the council setting its own target
to become carbon neutral but then by
approving this proposal
take it away from my household and for
my business
um i i invested a lot of my
time effort and money to achieve
what you say you want to achieve
and by approving this development you
will agree to take that achievement
that benefit away
if i had time i could mention how the
development will harm the surrounding
listing listed buildings
and the heritage of the area but i
haven't got the time
instead i want to tell the committee
that i have friends and neighbors
living in the conservation area of the
town that need to get approval from the
council to prune the trees in their
gardens
these good people have watched as the
council did nothing
when the land owner of this development
bulldoze the boundary for the
conservation area on the land
if the conservation area is important to
you
please protect it if i had time
i could discuss the long-term harm to
the landscape value of the valley
if these disappointing houses are built
when it's gone
it's gone forever i could tell you
that no business in torrington makes
money from the wonderful views of the
valley
i could tell you how much we would love
maybe a garden center there
with a cafe overlooking the valley a
real draw for the town
something like that would have
far-reaching benefits for the local
economy
just as the waiters um
would have had a a um
a benefit for the the economy as well
but that will but but that will never
happen any economic benefit to that this
land
will never happen if the land is used
for a small
uh scale estate with drab looking
dwellings
i would i could suggest to the committee
that maybe
the payment of 93 000 pounds from the
developer
in these cash-strapped times is enough
to cloud judgment
as to if problems are bad enough to deal
with
or just pass them over at this time
i would like to have a lawyer look into
the numerous significant problems
with this outline proposal but as uh but
as the officers report
only gave one working day
to get a response together i humbly ask
yourselves
to delay this decision to give more time
to allow that to happen
that thank you mr whitney you've had
just over three minutes actually now but
thank you very much for your
contribution
pleasure okay the next uh
public speaker is colin porter are you
there mr porter
i am yes all right thanks mr porter you
have three minutes also to present your
case
thank you good morning chairman ladies
and gentlemen
that was a very detailed and thorough
presentation by helen smith if i had
half an hour
as well i would be able to give you a
lot more information
but i've only got three minutes so i'll
stick to script
my concerns are not with the development
as a whole but with the visual impact
of the south side of the development on
the torres valley
here in torridge we have valued
landscapes we have albertson cliffs
we have northern boroughs we have the
valley of the torridge
it is that part of the torch valley
below torrington that we are discussing
this morning
the proposal clearly shows a significant
change
in the visible profile of the skyline
helens uh helen's
very attractive selection of photographs
were somewhat deceptive
the uh they were taken from the low
side low down in the valley the
sectional drawing in the plans
takes its sight line from lower than
halfway
up the road on the other side of the
valley
this this valley this development will
be viewed from
higher up the other sides of the valley
i should refer the meeting to the
following local documents
the devon structure plan 2001
2016 in which it says
visually intrusive development in
settlements and on skylines belong
beyond the character is avoided and that
it aims to protect framed visitors and
views across the valley
the landscape planning guideline in the
landscape strategy for the torridge
valley
says that its aim is to protect
the lightly settled and tranquil
character of the landscape ensuring
that new development on the edges of
nearby settlements does not
encroach into the area these are
documents
that uh uh exist these are documents
that were commissioned by
you yourselves your predecessors
counselors and officers
the policy env
env6 designated landscape area which
covers this
part says that in the areas of great
landscape value which is the torridge
valley
shown on the proposal's map development
should not detract from the particular
landscape qualities and characteristics
that have led to the designation of that
area
large-scale development that could be
accommodated elsewhere or the need for
which could be resolved
in some other way and and that that's
what hasn't happened
so so that's that's why i i have those
particular concerns
if like like the other valued areas um
that i've mentioned with within our
district if we lose these now then
generations ahead of us will not have
them we'll they'll not be able to
appreciate them so
so there must be some modification made
to
the from my point of view to the
proposal on the
edge of of the proposed development site
thank you
thank you mr porter thank you for your
contribution
right the third speaker that we've got
this one is matt steer
who's the agent are you there mr steer
yes i am chair thank you very much and
you have you have three minutes as well
to present
to the committee thank you thank you
thank you very much chair uh good
morning um
i'd just like to touch upon a few a few
comments raised um
very recently by members of the public
in their objection letters
i just want to just first uh just
mention about the town council's
response
um in the town councils once they
alluded to the provision
of bungalows on the site obviously we've
been through extensive
work with historic england since the
last time we
we get uh we came forward to planning
committee back in august
and it was concluded and supported by
historic england as the planning office
alluded to
in the scale of development that we're
proposing here today
um there was no context for bungalow and
single story form we've
we've managed to achieve the variation
in roof heights utilizing
good quality architecture in my opinion
in terms of that varied roof scape to
reflect
um the higher level above just touching
on then further to the very recent
um object objection response from uh
the lawyer in respect of uh mr
whitaker's um
initial objections i just want to touch
on those in uh
for for a moment um the the concept that
actually through a reserve matters
application the public won't be involved
is it is a new one on myself
i think they will be um so therefore
there is this um
there is this second round of public
consultation that will review the
appearance
and the landscaping elements of any
reserve matters application
so i think that actually deals with that
point in terms of further public
engagement
through a reserve matters application i
think in terms of the independent
um consultation for the overshadowing we
also undertook
our own um uh review of that
actually the figures were very very
similar between our own
uh our own process and the independent
process which gives us some
validity that i think we're in the in
the region of being accurate in that
position
what i would say is also if the panels
aren't constructed in
accordance with the um in accordance
with the permission i think that raises
other
other fundamental questions about the
validity of the current planning
application mr whitaker has but i think
we'll
we'll pass on that one in terms of any
any further comments and i think the
final comment i want to just mention is
about the five-year land supply
obviously um that was determined earlier
this year pre-covered
i think it's unreasonable and actually
not in accordance with the local plan
guidance in terms of reviewing
five year land supplies at every
opportunity for every
residential application that comes
forward it's reviewed on an annual basis
as per the local plan request
but actually i think if we actually did
do that test right now with three
three months of the construction
industry being put with downing tools
due to cobit i think the position is
probably worse
so actually in in reality it's probably
not a good suggestion to actually
undertake
a five-year land supply um review at
this moment in time but just do it in
accordance with the
the policies as stated in the local plan
so ultimately
i'd just like to um i'd just like to
reiterate my support for the obviously
for the uh planning office decision
i think this application should be
approved and would urge the committee to
follow suit thank you
thank you mr steer and our final
contribution this morning comes from
ward member
councillor cottle humpkin and councillor
cottle honking
there's no time limit on your
presentation to commit
oh god so it's not too long don't worry
um firstly i do want to start by
thanking the council
and the applicant for working together
with historic england
to revise the plans which do appear to
have improved
particularly in terms of the impact on
the skyline and historic townscape when
viewed from across the valley
having said that the previous plans were
particularly damaging on the landscape
and the new plan still remains
objectionable
and is still intrusive on the escarpment
edge
the town council has also highlighted a
number of valid concerns which are
contained within the report
local residents and the town council
plans committee
feel that single level buildings would
be more acceptable than two-story in
this location
i also feel the emphasis should be given
to historic england's recommendation
that the dwelling on plot 2 would be
better situated
further back from the valley edge
if the listed and currently prominent
historic feature of great torrington's
townscape
caneton house is to be regarded as a
building whose appearance on the
escarpment edge is to be valued
then it makes little sense to place the
plot two house further forward
the proposed development would also lead
to a loss of privacy in the rooms on the
east side of the house and in the garden
which would be looked down upon and
there is also concern that the house on
plot 2
would be elevated to facilitate sewage
drainage
which would obviously have a further
significant impact
on the aesthetics of the skyline the
need to elevate it would be unnecessary
as there are alternatives for the sewage
drainage
albeit more expensive i see that there
are a number of conditions included in
the report
and having spoken to residents in the
local community
we would like to add extra conditions or
revive
plans to include sufficient screening
between the development and cainton
house
relocating the dwelling on plot 2
further back from the valley edge
and making them single story which would
allow them to nestle into the landscape
ensuring there is no access for vehicles
from any part of the site onto mill
street
and restricting it to pedestrian access
only
there is actually also questioning of
the ownership of the historic footpath
which runs through the north of the site
onto mill street
and whether this can legally be included
in the plot
ensuring that blueprints for the houses
cannot be increased in size
at a later date ensuring that the
heights of the houses cannot be elevated
above
above a certain height for any reason
that might come forward at a later date
such as sewage issues last but not least
there is the issue of the neighboring
solar array which was granted permission
by this council
to allow a local business to run and to
be carbon neutral
as a council we are striving for carbon
neutrality
and are actively encouraging others to
do the same
the legal information received by the
council yesterday
tells us that a complicated planning
application of this kind
should be put forward in full and not
outline and that if permission
is granted at this point in time it
would be open to legal challenge
i'm sure this is not something that the
council wishes to experience
and that can be easily overcome by
refusing this application
and asking the applicant to reapply with
a full planning application
instead of just outline thank you for
letting me speak
thank you councillor cottle honking
right it's now
open to at the committee to discuss
um councillor brown do you want to start
the ball rolling on this
or not you've still got that cross up
against your name
you hear me now yes yes i can hear you
thank you chair i first of all i would
want to
point to um st04
which says development will achieve high
quality
inclusive and sustainable design to
support the creation of successful
vibrant places design will be
based on a clear process analyzes and
responds
to the characteristics of the site its
wider context
and the surrounding area take in full
account of the principles of design
found in policy dm4
now i as you will know now the
um neighborhood um plant the great
torrent of neighborhood plan is
is now available and can be considered
in planning it's
material um and 7.3 of that neighborhood
plan states that the development will be
of high quality
well designed to fit in with a local
area and contribute to creating a strong
sense of place
and also policy in the envy one
landscape protection which states
that developments will be supported
which demonstrate sensitivity to the
distinctive landscape character
of the area by retaining local features
now the the first one chair is that i
would like
to support um mr wicker whiskers um
statements because actually
in section 8.2 of the great torrential
plan says the importance of renewable
energy actually contributes to national
carbon reduction target
so that is something that rick
torrington feels very strongly about
and also seven um 0.3 does say as well
redevelopment must be of high quality
and well designed to fit in with the
local area i'll leave that for a minute
chariot and be
chairman and be interested to hear what
others say thank you
thank you councillor brown uh
who else would like to speak on this one
any hands up
nope council lock yeah
um i'll leave the solar panels to my
last
um observations um
historic england on page 23 i mean
they've said now that
their involvement is no longer required
because they consider that the plans
will significantly reduce levels of harm
to the historic environment
and on page 27 um the commons
conservatives
i just like to ask the officer are these
fresh comments on the new layer or do
they
refer to the original plans please
um yes i'll answer that point councillor
lock so
um the way the representations are set
out that there aren't many actually that
have come in in respect
of the new scheme and i can confirm that
the great
and common conservatives comments on
page 27
are in relation to the original proposal
not the current
proposal that's before you thank you for
that um and also on page 18
our conservation officer says um
that the height of the new buildings are
very very similar to those at the
waitrose store
um now regarding the solar panels
when you see the photographs of them i
think the officer stated that there's no
real defined boundary
between the garden and the applications
like just
two blocks or something
i think there was just a broken down
stone wall there you can see it
yeah so i mean if if this application
um was granted or even um if it
wasn't granted the owners of the
application site
could they insist that a higher boundary
wall
be built um
chair would you like me to respond on
that point now yeah
so so the the applicants could without
the need for planning permission
put up a two meter fence along that
along that boundary
um similarly you know the most recent
use of the site is as a market garden
as you can see the boundary immediately
um
to the left of this image there is
vegetation that's grown up
trees could be planted within the
application site without
needing planning permission so you know
that that is something that could happen
you would normally expect a residential
cartilage to have at least sort of a 1.8
meter
boundary fence in normal circumstances
and just one final point about the solar
panel was mr whitaker mentioned
about um should the application
be granted and houses are built the
owners of the property nearest his
um solar panels could in fact plant
trees
but that has been conditioned yeah 16
conditions 16 yeah that has been
conditioned so that won't happen
um i'll wait for the comments until i
hear from other councils
thank you council a lot councillor
craigie
thank you chair um i'd like to support
the town council in this one
i think this is an over development of
the site
it's a very very beautiful area just
there
and we have to value and protect
areas like that i think a small
development of bungalows would be
would have been much more appropriate
and i i think it
it boils down to the fact of greed again
the the developers just want to maximize
profit
that is their motivation we have to bear
that in mind that we don't have to go
along with what developers want to do
we can say no and i'm afraid in this
particular case i
i won't say no thank you
thank you councillor craigie well
no other hands up at the minute so
councillor christie
yeah thank you um i'd just like to
reiterate what counselor craig you've
just said because
it is a very small plot and
trying to squeeze quite so many houses
on does seem it's the old thing you know
caught into a point pot again um the
other thing that does worry me is
this is a sight on the edge of a very
prominent hill
now i suspect you've all heard the
expression uh great origin
is the english jerusalem because it is
supposed to have this
uh similarity when viewed from down the
bottom of that if you look up to
the skyline of jerusalem i can't say
i've ever seen it
but it does highlight the impact of any
developments on the skyline
and i find this really unsympathetic
development and i'm afraid i'm not
impressed by the arguments that have
been put forward to
allow it to go ahead thank you
thank you councillor christie councillor
watson yeah thank you chair
well
i i i was on the committee when when
waitrose was approved
nah this is why i i must admit i asked
ellen smith to show me the
um the difference between the the
the houses these houses and the waitrose
store
waitrose store if i believe that was
closer
to the edge of the um
of the footpath uh which was going to be
all open
etc etc uh
a very very different style of building
uh as as he usually is with a with us
um a superstar um
these these houses in my opinion um
will look much better than a waitrose
store
the height over me it is roughly the
same
the principle of development is already
there
and there are various things no
i mean there's no controller at the
minute what couldn't be planted trees
at any time southwest water have got no
objection
historic england is now broadly
supported of the proposal
um how long has the solar panels been
there
have the solar panels been there since
since waitrose was there
we're going to build i'd i'd like to
know that to be quite honest
um how are far away from
from the the house the houses at the top
of that site
are away from actually away from the
solar panels
and if the application was that the
solar panel should have been 10 meters
away from the boundary why are there
only nine
so at this moment in time i i feel that
i'm quite happy with this
with with this application and it is far
better than the first one that they put
in
i thought that was wasn't good at all
but i'm sure that this one
will be fine uh the car park like i
remember about
the waitress went when the raido's
application was there people were
complaining that oh it will take all
all the car parking spaces uh away and
etc etc well waitrose was you gonna use
a
very large part of the car park whereas
now this
this isn't there are plenty still plenty
of spaces there for
for other cars to park so at this moment
in time i'm
i'm looking to
well see what somebody else wants to say
but i
i just don't i i i'd like some of them
questions answered
ellen please to be quite honest thank
you
chair would you like me to go back on
those those points yeah
yeah yeah um just to respond to
councillor watson's
um question there in terms of the solar
array it was granted permission
um in june so august 2018
i i don't know how long they've actually
been there but certainly they
they wouldn't have been there before
august 2018
the the waitrose permission would have
expired in june
of that year the the reason the panels
needed permission is because they are in
the cartilage of a listed building so
they do not benefit from permitted
development
rights in this location hence the need
for an application to
to be submitted um condition two of
the permission for the solar panels
requires
um them to be carried out in accordance
with the approved plans i
you know in terms of the distance from
the boundary if it isn't what was
approved then
then stayed there you know in breach of
that condition
um i think i can say on that really did
that answer your question
counselor watson yeah that's fine that's
fine ellen thanks very much
i'll see what somebody else wants to say
man thank you
well i've got no other blue hands up at
the minute oh
cancel the lock again yeah just coming
back on that point about the solar
eraser if they were
put in in 2018 um
the applicant would have been aware that
there was
um if if the waitrose application was
granted in 15 it was still live in 2018
so i would have thought that um the
owners of number three
mill street would have been aware that
there was um
a planning application in for that site
um and i think the officer has confirmed
that there will be no
vehicle access um from the site onto
meal street so i think that's an
important point because there were
several objections about that
um so i'm also mine to support the
application
chair could i just come come in on one
point that counselor look
just raised there um i think it's
important just to confirm that
at the time of um mr whittaker
submitting his application for the solar
panels
which i believe it was registered on the
29th of june
2018 the waitrose application would have
expired
a matter of days earlier so so at the
time of the application being submitted
there wasn't an extant
permission for waitrose albeit it had
only very recently expired
okay okay thank you can i just could i
just come back and
yeah go on council boxing uh that's fine
ellen yeah i do understand that but
surely
surely um surely they should have known
that there was
the principle of development was still
on that site
and whether it be a waitrose store or
something else could have come up to be
built on it
maybe maybe tesco might have thought
well okay
we'll put a little store on there you
know so what i would that
you know that would be the same
principle yeah
i'm just coming back on that point
councillor council watson yes
of course i mean it's planning history
as a material
consideration the the policy policy
context
um at that time was was obviously the
previously adopted plan we are a
different policy context now but the
principles are the same
the sites within the development
boundary and so
you know that there are high
sustainability credentials
for this site that that support it for
for
development thank you helen um
i've no other hands at the minute so
councillor brown
you're muted that's better can hear you
know
cancer i want to go back to a couple of
references from councillor christine
and craigie this site does about
to an area of national beauty it's a
recognized
place the most famous indoor inland
section in in the country um
it is our jewel in the crown as he said
and i also wanted to say
that the housing needs in our area
if if fully explored will say
that many older people will downsize
but there are no bungalows provided
and this is why town council apart from
the appearance
on this site bungalows would be a far
better
better provision um so therefore um
german i would want to refuse this
application
thank you thank you councillor brown
right will there's no other hand at
present so i'll
have my say on it i was pleased to hear
all the contributions from everybody and
i think it was right that we
really did assess the issue of the solar
panels that cropped up
quite late on really when you look at
the plan in front of us now showing the
weight rules or the weight roll store
that did receive planning permission
for me that would have far more of a
detrimental impact
on on the conservation area and the
heritage aspect
of great torrington than this proposed
development
in front of us now yeah the front of the
weight rolls
and i know it really i think achieved
planning permission because of the
perceived benefit to the economy of
great torrington but it was a lot
further forward as you can see from that
and it did have a balcony that little
red bit at the front was an actual
sitting out balcony for a cafe
which would have overlooked the valley
it would have had far more impact
than this and i do accept they've looked
at it again
with the intervention of the english
heritage and moved
moved it back from where it was the
housing back
from the edge from where it was
originally shown to be and they've also
opened it up in front there so the view
from across the valley from
and we saw the photographs that helen
presented one from the car park at
rosemoor
looking across to this site cainton
house is the one that we all
our eyes drawn to uh and because they
they've moved this back down and opened
the front up to have this
light render horseshoe shape or this
courtyard effect
that's really has lessened the impact of
the view of this
development from the valley when you
look at the site itself it's just an
overgrown jungle now
it's it it's not a wood it would land
it's not it's just
and i saw really on the end of the car
park as far as i can see
the solar panels i do accept that
there'll be a and it's been admitted in
the independent report
there will be a slight effect of
overshadowing
in the winter months december january
february
but there's a tree there currently and
there are trees next door which i'm sure
in the summertime must have an effect on
those panels
and certainly the tree on the site which
is to be retained
that that's shown to overshadow a great
deal at certain times of the year
so it's not as if there is no currently
no overshadowing
at certain times of the year happening
on these panels
perhaps with hindsight it would have
been better have been sighted
bit further up the garden or on a higher
frame
but i don't believe that the effect on
the solar panels
is that great i mean it's minimal and i
think
we had a presentation at like 18 pound
46 of electricity
may have to be bought in the winter
months um
one thing i would and i'm going to move
that we accept the recommendation to
grant this
one thing i would add though is we are
going to put
we want a condition obviously for the
management and maintenance of the open
space and
helen mentioned that at the start but i
would also like if this
is granted the protected species on site
i don't want
if this outlines granted a bulldozer
going in tomorrow and clearing that site
so there should be a condition in this
outline that
the protected species on site must be
dealt with before
anything is shifted on that site before
any clearing is done
the protected species must be dealt with
um but i'm
i'll i'll move the recommendation to
prove because
i think it's the best that can be
achieved with that i do hear what
counselor brown said it
about bundle rules and i'm always
banging the drum for one of those
but i think in this location there are
other sites
i think probably better suited for some
vulnerable development
in toronto in great terms yeah um
i'll second it if you're proposing in
last second thanks councillor watson
um is that what yeah is that what your
hand was up for then
what my hand was up for right can i
bring in council
count council lock and then sean
harrington
i was also going to second the proposal
council watson got there first
thank you sean i'll bring you in ah
thank you chair
um in relation to the um ecological
condition you just referred to there is
condition uh condition 10
uh proposed um in terms of relocation
dormouse and
reptile and the survey that was
undertaken
did the chair wish to see an additional
condition above over and above that
condition
and if so would the chair be happy that
that's delegated to officers in
conjunction with the chair
thank you does that be does that protect
does that stop a bulldozer going in if
this is granted an outline
does does 10 stop a bulldozer going in
tomorrow and clearing the site
yeah it requires further details um that
needs to be accepted by the local
planning authority
uh which would include um timings of
works and timings of uh
relocation or protected species okay
well
i'm happy with that then sure sean thank
you very much on that
so the only one we want to add is a
condition about this management and
maintenance
of the open space yeah i think a lot of
the issues that have been raised
more to do with the reserve matters
application you know the design and the
look of the site
and as helen said positioning of windows
etc
that'll all come forward in a reserved
matters but as an outline application
um i'm quite satisfied with it
members right well it's been it's nobody
else wants to speak now so it's been
moved
and seconded to approve this one can we
go to the vote please caster
thank you chair councillor belton at
fourth
councillor brown
against thank you councillor christie
councillor craigie against
councillor leather four
councillor lock or councillor mcgoff
against councillor watson
so that's five four and four against
chair thank you kirsty
so so that is approved then that outline
application is approved
okay thank you we'll move on then
right our next the next application is
application
b which is an outline application
for the old telephone exchange at bucks
cross and
and angelo massos the officer will
present this
application thanks angelo thank you
chair good morning again members and
members of the public
um as the cherished has mentioned we
have an
application for outline permission with
all matters reserved
for a single dwelling on the old
telephone exchange
uh near bucks cross and i'll go into
detail
within the following slides about the
characteristics of the site
next slide please
so the image before you shows an aerial
image of the site
in relation to the settlement bucks
cross which is approximately
1.1 kilometers to the west
to the west of the site which comprises
with the provision of services of a
village shop
post office community hall and a caravan
holiday park
as you can see the site is indicated by
the red arrow
and just to the north of the site is
more recently the atlantic
academy secondary school which is set
within
north devon aomb the site
is linked uh two bucks across as you can
see
from the a39 but attached and just
running parallel to the the a39 is an
unclassified highway
which has no provision of safe means of
pedestrian access
to bucks cross you can have next slide
please
here's a zoomed in aerial image of the
site
um which is the
indicates the uh the former bt telephone
exchange
building which is currently a disused
and subsequently now
redundant building the the site is
triangular in shape
we've established hedgerow boundaries
and trees
and it does have an agricultural access
that runs to the site
um as some of you may be also aware
where
the site has been subject to numerous uh
previous
proposals for residential development
which
were deemed unsustainable by both plans
committee
and the planning inspectorate on the
pills
okay next slide please
so here we have an indicative site
plan which shows that a
dwelling can be accommodated within the
site
as well as provision for access drainage
and immunity space
and turning for parking so on um
next slide please
here is a view from the a39 by the
school bus
lay by and then subsequently to the
right hand side of the slide is a view
from
the junction that leads towards the site
with the arrow indicating
direction towards the site
next slide please
hey so these are two views of the
existing site entrance
to the site so as you can see um it's
very much within a rural setting with
immediate sort of characteristics of
vegetation
established trees native hedgerow banks
and boundaries uh to the right hand side
you can see a
more zoomed in uh photo of the immediate
site entrance with the
unclassified highway to the left this
existing site entrance immediate front
of you
and then the agricultural access to the
right hand side
next slide please here's a photo the
existing redundant and disused building
as you can see has been subsequently
left for a number of years and
vegetation has started to colonize
on the building itself
so here's a view of the northern
boundary
from the unclassified highway this is a
view from
east to west it's going towards bucks
cross
next slide please
slide please sorry helen um so this is a
view
from the entrance uh looking west
towards
bucks cross uh along the oh sorry that's
one too many helen
okay so this is a view looking west from
the site entrance towards bucks cross
which shows the unclassified highway
that leads
running parallel to the a39
and here is a view of the unclassified
highway
junction and a view towards the a39
that both lead from the site and lead to
and from the site
next slide please so the material
planning considerations in this case
have been
expressed in detail within the officers
reports and are as
follows the principal development
character and appearance
neighboring immediacy highways
found surface water drainage ecology
and the plan imbalance the application
has been recommended for
refusal as outlined in detail within
the report me in this application i'd
like to take
take a moment to say thank you for
listening to both members and
of the council and the public and i'll
pass you back to the
chair to discuss the following
application
thank you thank you angelo thanks for
that presentation
um we've got
well four contributors public
contributions for this application
the first is in support of it from
debbie and she sent in a statement to be
read by
our planning manager sean harrington so
sean if you'd like to read
debbie newcombe's contribution
yes thank you chair um okay this is
a statement from w newcomb on behalf of
our eight row
architectural design agents councillors
thank you for thank you for allowing me
to address the committee
this proposed site is located adjacently
a39
and so has good road links to all areas
the hub of bux cross is centered around
the shop but spreads in all directions
to a distance similar to that of this
application site
not all the pavements westbrook's bux
mills the holiday site and the area
towards the churchyard
are all a distance similar to the old
telephone exchange
whilst lying outside any defined
development boundary
it is considered to be a brownfield site
suitable for redevelopment
this was confirmed by the plans
committee when application 1-0452-2013-4
was presented
the proposal for approval was narrowly
lost by the cast and votable chairperson
this was more based on the size of the
dwelling rather than location of its
present use
if approved a modded size dwelling would
be designed appropriately site and its
surroundings
since then the landscape and built form
around the site has significantly
changed
the building in the aomb of the
secondary school atlantic academy
opposite
this has involved street lighting bus
stops and a pavement link from the track
adjacent to the site onto the main a39
the site can no longer be considered to
be open conditions with this fast
development opposite no objections have
been received from any of the consultees
including the parish council who support
the application letters of support have
been submitted from neighbours on the
site
in policy terms an important fact to
consider in the redevelopment of this
brownfield site
is the recent burwood appeal which
identified that council cannot
demonstrate a five-year
land supply and therefore policy sto-7
is not relevant
at a national level mppf open market
housing is supported in all areas
not just those defined by development
boundary scenario
while xbox cross has a development
boundary new dwelling should not be
confined to sites within it
the track running parallel to the a59
has a number of properties along it
leading to the proposed site to box
across whilst there isn't a pavement
link the track is only used to serve
dwellings and to provide a safe walking
route to the centre of bucks cross
it is accepted that the existing
building does not meet the minimal
technical housing standard
but could be converted with an extension
and therefore would be in accordance
with policy dm27 and dm25
paragraph 118 or the mbpf encourages the
redevelopment of brownfield sites
stating as follows give substantial
weight to the value of using suitable
brownfield land within settlements
for homes and other identified needs and
support appropriate opportunities to
remediate
despoiled degraded derelict contaminated
or unstable land
to get together with policy stl2 or the
north dakota
charity local plan supports and
encourages the redevelopment of
previously developed land
it's considered that the proposal meets
both national and local policy
i would disagree with the planning
officer's comment regarding isolated
location
the site is adjacent to the a49 and as
stated above is well related to bucks
cross
given the real nature of the torch
district reliance on a private car
is heavy even in towns the location of
this site ensures easy access to nearby
villages
which in these strange times need even
more support to sustain local shops pubs
and community facilities
power 11d of the mppf which is of
significance
refers to protecting areas of important
aomb
it can be argued that the existing
building falling into disrepair
would cause more harm on adjacent aomb
than a well-designed dwelling on the
site
it is also relevant that the atlantic
academy has caused great impact on the
amb in this area
and therefore the impact of a single
dwelling adjacently a and b would not
cause harm
this outline application does not
provide details on any future design
but obviously this will be submitted as
part of reserve matters application
which can be considered by your officer
any design will be carefully considered
to ensure that it is sympathetic to its
surroundings and fits into the landscape
the dwelling would be of modest scale to
ensure that it suits the size of the
site and does not appear cramped or over
developed
screening along the boundaries of the
site would be retained replanted to
minimize the impact of a dwelling
we feel that the development of this
redundant brownfield site is ideally
suited for a family home for the
applicant
thank you chair thank you sean
uh our second contributor is the
applicant themselves
uh edward cerner who sent in a statement
again
for uh uh our planning manager sean to
read out
thank you a statement to be read on
behalf of edward cerner
regarding the outline planning
application on the box across telephone
exchange
i call on the councillors for help to
prove that a residential
dwelling is suitable on this redundant
unused site that stood empty for over 30
years
despite the need for local housing i
would like to address a number of points
raised by the planning officer in his
statement
1. planning policy has changed since
this application was first submitted in
1997.
within a mile radius of the site 17 new
homes have been built
a secondary school and two bus stops
two in 2013 i asked for a building with
a footprint of 82 square meters
committee at that time unanimously
agreed that this was a brownfield site
fit for residential development
but refused it as they thought the
property proposed was too big
after liaising with len head of planning
this was reduced to 47.5 square meters
for my 2014 application
but was never called in despite a
request for listed to be done
the average site for house is 333.5
square meters
this site is 525 square meters
three the planning officer makes
reference for the need of a car
the school and post office are within
walking distance of the proposed site
for myself my transport time from biddy
for two mary harriers would be reduced
the route 39 bus stops are used by
stagecoats under oppressed passengers as
drivers tend to have common sense and be
generally
helpful i would also like to point out
the recent government announcement that
all carbon field cars are to be phased
out by 2030.
the site has mains water and electricity
connected
the building is not of any architectural
merit and could be argued does not add
anything to its rural location
supporting letters have argued that a
residential building would help
safeguard the local community
by one being part of it and secondly
prevent people carrying out
ant antisocial behavior in the area such
as fly tipping and drug taking
five no detailed plans have been
submitted as this application is
disproved that a residential building
on the site is appropriate we are happy
to work with the planners to achieve a
building that fits in with surroundings
of appropriate size and meets the
highest
energy efficiency 6. i did apply for
pre-planning but received no response
hence feeling it necessary
to apply for outline planning to be able
to move forward instead of getting
bogged down with detailed design
but just to focus on principle
i am asking you to take a considered
approach on what can be agreed
if this was a barn in europe open
countryside
and i wanted to turn it into residential
dwelling you could find a policy to
support this
i would also like to draw attention to
the water tower at hiaclavelli
approved for residential use it has been
suggested that the site falls
outside of the bucks cross community i
would suggest that the community
boundary has moved due to the building
of the a39 academy
it is possible to walk to the post
office without walking on the a39
being part of a community does not
necessarily mean being able to walk to
the post office
not many of them are remaining rural
community life is about supporting one
another
i worked less than a mile from the
application my son was christened in
bucks mills
church i sponsored the park and pumpkin
pumpkin competition and as a family we
support watery school any way we can
i would like to think that my family is
part of this rural community yours truly
edward cerner
thank you thank you sean and now
you get your breath back another drop of
water for a minute sean if you want
because
the next contribution is from councillor
harding one of the board members
and again he sent a statement in to be
read by schwann
thank you chair it's a fairly short
statement so i i think i'd go ahead with
this one
um dear sean i'm unable to make the
planning committee for thursday so i'm
writing this letter of support for one
slash zero six four two
twenty twenty slash out at bucks cross o
telephone exchange
as ward counsellor i have knowledge of
both the property and the applicant
this application ticks all the boxes in
my mind it is well related to nearby
houses
it is close to bus stop allowing
sustainable travel it's a brownfield
site
it's opposite a secondary school it is a
small site and with the right
architect it will make a modest sized
family home as is outlined in planet
mission i'm sure with your officer
guidance this will sit well in its plot
thank you chair thank you sean and our
final contributor again is
another board member is councillor dart
and i know
councillor dart's present this morning
councillor dart if you'd like to give us
your
presentation please thank you chair
thank you committee um i didn't call
this application in but i have to say
that i
must speak in support of it um
and when planning what to say i
got to be honest with you debbie newcomb
has stole my thunder completely
because she mentioned everything she
mentioned was absolutely correct
um and i i just can't see that this is
not sustainable
the fact that it's a local family um
they
um contribute to the community um
it's they work really close to the site
so actually it could reduce carbon
emissions
the um old bucks road is the old main
road
so it's really a um
very quiet road it has sporadic
development right the way along it
and you can walk along that road with no
problem even though there's no pavement
there's no need for one to be a waste of
money
there's hardly any traffic along there
takes you straight to bucks you've got
the post office you've got the bus stop
there
um you know route 39 did set a president
in that particular area and yes there's
a bus stop there but
you know there there is amenity at bucks
and it's within walking distance i
really don't understand the big issue
with this um i don't think it'll be seen
from anywhere although i've not looked
at all the angles um
but certainly won't one would argue
stick out as much as route 39 does from
a distance but there we are that's by
the way
um at the end of the day i really don't
see a problem with it and uh
i was i was quite stunned that it's
recommended for a refusal again actually
thank you for letting me speak thank you
councilman dart
right um councilman benton you want to
start the ball rolling on this one
although i was i was one that called it
in yeah you did yeah
um but i um i come with a clear and open
mind basically i called it in for
reasons given but i
come with a clear and open mind
right thank you for that counselor but
did
well i don't usually speak first but i
will do on this because i'm
quite keen in to support this
application actually so
i've gone over everything and i do thank
angelo for his uh
report it was a very thorough report
um however this site is not the isolated
site that he makes so
there are neighbors just across the
adjoining field is a farm and the track
that was shown at the side um
of the the entrance to the site actually
leads to the farm but the farm doesn't
use that as its main entrance
but it's only across the f that track
that goes up the side
i think probably that aerial view is
better because it shows the other
properties i'm going to mention
there are further along the old road and
you can see them
just to the right of where it says a39
an atlantic
academy but there are two dwellings
there further along
you've got hilltop caravans further
along you've got more housing
but you can um
you can actually walk all the way or
cycle
all the way along into bucks cross along
that old road so there isn't any need
for any footpath
as councillor dart just said and the
site is well hidden from views in almost
every direction
it is a brownfield site and a modest
dwelling
there would have no detrimental impact
on the bucks cross area
it would however be an excellent use of
a very untidy
overgrown eyesore and fulfill the
criteria
of using previously developed land for
housing
and ppf 78 to promote sustainable
development
in rural areas housing should be located
where it will enhance
or maintain the valid vitality of rural
communities
this will do both it will enhance the
area if developed
properly and it certainly will support
the rural communities
and the facilities in box cross there
are services as
angelo mentioned books across as a post
office and store
community hall and one can quite easily
walk as i've said or cycle to the site
into bucks cross without the need to
access the a39
there's a bus service from box cross to
either biddeford orbit
so it is a very sustainable location in
actual fact
sto2 mitigating climate change literally
redevelop redeveloping previously
developed land
and reducing reusing and recycling
resources
including construction materials
providing for more efficient use of
facilities
and enhanced opportunities for recycling
it does not conflict with with sto4
improving the quality of development or
dmo
8 a landscape and seascape character
and as this is an outline application
dm04 design principles
is hardly engaged the parish council
unanimously
supports this application as do the five
local people who've submitted comments
it would seem that a modest house in
this location would actually help
with the enhancement of the area and
help guard against fly tipping
that's already been mentioned the
applicant is a local family who work
helping to run a family business
just outside bucks cross for me this
application hinges on
for me it does hinge on what
effect granting outline permission for
this site we'll have on the area
the site is not easily visible from any
viewpoint it does have a neighbor to the
south east
a farmhouse and the two of the houses
along
about 250 yards along to the west and
the caravan site again the old main road
which this site sits along runs all the
way through to bucks cross where it
joins
public footpath just short of the bus
stop
so i believe the application complies
with mppf
11d the presumption
uh one uh rule housing mppf
78 it also complies with sto2 literally
redeveloping previously developed land
st 21 brackets 2 rural areas strategy
and rural areas strategy stl7
brackets 3 and 4 with reference to 4.15
dm 27 reuse of disused and redundant
rural buildings a b d andy it complies
with all those
and at the end of it and i'm going to
shut up now
employing the tilted balance which i
believe is what we ought to do with this
it would i would recommend granting
outline planning permission
uh and as somebody said it takes it all
the box on it's councillor harding's
statement in his mind ticks all the
boxes for
a very modest development on that i'll
bring in counselor lock and then
councillor christie
yeah i mean i've i've been on i've been
involved in the last two applications
for this site when they were reviews and
i again
drove up to the site i think it was on
sunday and i still cannot believe that
they can get even a modest house
on the site um i do take into account
what character dart
said um you don't have to use your car
because you could use the old road and
it's not very far from butts across the
post obviously the bus stops
um and it will make good use of a brown
site
my only concern is um
the comments on page 50
from building control it would be a very
large hole when dug out from 36
thousand liter um tank have we got any
indications where this tank's going to
go so i think it said it was going to go
in the entrance
which could be um with cars going in and
out
from the occupants of the house it might
damage the tank so
but i don't think there's anywhere else
on the site where that where the water
tank can go is that
you know it shows it on that indicative
site plan there now cancel a lot
yeah i mean if it's if it's if that tank
was
put in the ground properly and the
concrete driver paved drive over the top
the car's not i don't think the cars can
affect it
that that would be my only concern okay
thanks counselor yeah chair i'm sorry
i put my hand up too counselor christie
thank you um yeah my mind goes back to
when
um the application for the atlantic um
academy was first put in porridge
actually opposed that of course we
opposed it very strongly it went to
appeal it lost it appeal but we were
overruled by michael gove who said no
you couldn't see any problems with it
having said that um i think we now have
to be pragmatic because that school is
there
it's a huge development and
this house is actually fairly close to
it well i say house this building is
fairly close to it
and uh i suspect if this was a barn it
would probably just get nodded through
as a
barn redevelopment so i can't see much
of a problem with redeveloping an old
building so
our second uh council letter i don't
think anyone else has seconded you yet
but i will second your
uh proposal to um allow us
thank you councilman christa angelo
you've got your hand up
thank you chair i just wanted to remind
councillors
that uh when considering the principle
of development for this site
the starting point is the local plan and
the spatial strategy
adopted in the local plan and policies
which outline that specifically is the
bucs cross policy
which doesn't have any allocated
development within that
development boundary which is very much
tightly
knit close around the existing built
form
of bux cross it does allow the provision
of
a single or modest development to
contribute
to the existing limited provision of
services of bucks cross however
it does only allow exceptional
development to be
to be brought forward and i would like
just to remind councillors that
the exceptional circumstances that could
bring forward development within such a
location as proposed
um as stated within
the mppf paragraph 79
on page 51 of your agenda which goes
over to page 52
there are exceptions that you could put
forward the conversion of a disuse and
redundant building
and in this instance this building would
meet that aspect
of national policy and our local plan
policy of dm
27 notwithstanding that the
building is not considered capable of
conversion without substantive
alterations and extensions and i would
just also like to remind councillors
this would fail on national policy
and local policy and has already been
historically tested
and dismissed on appeal by the planning
inspectorate
and therefore we would consider it not
to be
compliant to be able to be reused
for residential purpose in this instance
and therefore
i just also like to remind councillors
about the
the site is a brownfield site which does
provide
sto2 does provide and principal support
to reuse
sites however i just like to reiterate
that policy sto2
reinforces the sustainability principles
of the spatial strategy of sto7 and
buxcross and
and therefore i would say it would be
considered
unsustainable in accordance to relation
to the
development boundary of bucks across um
thank you angelo i did look at the plan
the development boundary box cross and
as you've said
quite rightly said it's a very tightly
drawn boundary that is
uh councillor watson did you want to
speak to this one yeah yeah i just
just a few words check uh going back to
the indicative site plan um the proposal
of the
36 000 lead to a cesspool
if that's done properly it will it won't
be a problem for cars to drive over it
uh because it'll be it will be very very
very deep into the ground to be quite
honest
so i i don't have a problem with that uh
my problem originally was the diverting
of the
the the water main and that looks uh
you know diverting it like if if that's
the diverted
water main then yeah okay
that may be okay but yeah apart from
that you know i
i understand where angelo's coming from
um
but i also understand you know where
council dart was coming from
so i think that i i think i could
support this
thank you councillor councilman mcgove
very nice mr chairman i'm in full
agreement with you mr chairman i support
this application
i find that bursting opinions is
sustainable
i agree with council harding's uh few
brief words that he
done that mr harrison read out um and to
pick up the point that council christie
raised about the
route 39 just opposite the major
development there
i mean we have to be like-minded that
went through
regardless which way it went at a time i
see this as a sustainable development
and a brownfield
site which needs to be dealt with and
council watson's
uh concerns about a cesspool and the the
water mains running through
i echo what you said council watson so
i'm in full agreement with this
application
actually councilman sean sean harrington
wants to come in
uh thank you chair um yeah
i mean the uh the comments made by
yourself chair are fairly uh pharah with
regard to
the support from the policy perspective
um as the planning officer has stated
um when we look at our policies and we
look at the tips balance
it's your professional office's view
that the
application should be refused for the
reasons that's put
within your report however if members
are minded to
look at a differing decision i think
members do need to discuss whether they
consider the site to be isolated or not
and therefore whatever power 79 of the
mppf comes into play
i think that was touched upon within the
early discussions but
you may want to discuss that further and
also we've got a tilted balance
you have discussed sustainability
location um but you may want to discuss
that further
and also the reuse of the brownfield
sites um i know that councillor christie
did
second but i'm not sure whether counts
the yourself
council ever actually put forward a
proposal but if you do you also want to
be considering
um the conditions attached to that um
and there would certainly be some
conditions in relation to the foul
drainage that's been discussed by
council lock
but of course we can just discuss that
further if members wish us to
many thanks thank you sean yeah i will
make
it a firm proposal because i am keen
that this site
does get developed eventually um the
sustainability
on the balance on the tilted balance i
was just looking at um
the decision taken and this means i'm
looking
at 11 d now and it says any
adverse impacts of doing so would
significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits when assessed
against the policies in this framework
taken as a whole so the sustainability
of the site
i don't think to be honest is in
question because
you don't need it you don't need a car
necessarily although everybody living in
the rural
areas do need transport but you you
wouldn't have to necessarily have that
um because you can cycle from this site
you walk from the site as i said earlier
there's a bus stop on the main road
there and it is a request stop as well
as the one
nearer to box cross so the site is
sustainable
it's not visible i mean we i think
councillors have been on before council
lock knows the site well
i drove out there again the other day
just it's not visible from anywhere
really because
it sits along what site used to be the
main road
until we put the new a39 over the other
side so
even with the trees it not in leaf now
you hardly know it's there but i would
put one condition on that the band
and it is proposed to keep the existing
hedge bank
i will condition that they should be
retained um
along the lay by access road as it's
called and also along the back
but is it on the indicative plan there
it does say
they there to be retained the existing
hedge banks they should be conditioned
um i accept what
council watson have said and councilman
goff
they're involved in in building
i can't see a problem be put in the tank
there i did read the tank has to be at a
lower level
and that's why it's got to be cited
there really it can't be at a higher
level because
you don't want it any potential for any
effluent flowing into the house so it's
got to be at that level
um yeah
i i think it just complies i read out i
i i it does comply with mppf11d
little two and rural housing mppf78
it complies with sto2 little e
redeveloping previously developed land
and reducing reusing and recycling
resources
including construction materials
providing for more efficient use of
facilities
and enhanced opportunities for recycling
so it does comply with that
um
st 21 little two
it complies with that i believe sto7
spatial development strategy
for northern devon's rural area where
you've got the list there
of the the villages
in the area uh dm 27 reserved is used in
redundant rural buildings
it takes all those boxes as a b the only
one it doesn't is c because c
says development can be achieved without
significant
external durations extension or
substantive rebuilding
that may not be possible but all the
others a
such conversion would not harm any
intrinsic qualities
and historic interests of the building
the proposal will have a positive impact
on the immediate setting of the building
and the wider rural characters protected
ticks that one
d suitable highway access can be
provided and the
surrounding highway network can support
the proposed use
uses and any nature conservation
interest
within the building or wider site is
retained
sean
uh thank you chair um yeah just to
confirm with the
policies particularly with dm 27
that a proposal would have to comply
with all relevant elements as opposed to
some if it failed on a element it
wouldn't comply with that
policy just a technical interpretation
of the policy and how we need to
apply the policies um although i did
note um
you know what you're saying about the
tilted balance and about the location
being sustainable within bucks cross and
supporting
that settlement in line with power 78 um
but yeah i i just need to be said that
if the um
if the proposal didn't if we are called
with one element of policy
such as uh dm27 then it wouldn't accord
that whole policy um
so yeah i just want members to be aware
of that would it be useful at this stage
given where this um this discussion is
going
to discuss um conditions that members
would want to see
put on this proposal given it is an
outline proposal and it is a brownfield
site so likely contamination etc um
again your officers are here uh to help
you on that if that seemed
as a fitting time to do that yeah i know
so
i did notice um
in the report it mentions about coming
forward with a reserved matters
application
there'll be things to comply with
possible contamination of the site needs
to be put
in there um because it has been an
industrial use with the telephone
exchange there
but i would put a time limit of two
years on for them to come forward with
the reserve matters on the site
because we want this to add even in its
limited way with one dwelling to the
lack of housing in the area
the fact we haven't got this five year
land supply it does add
but the main thing is as well it does
support the services
in bucks cross which for me is a key
issue
in considering this application and as i
said the return
tension of those hedges
sean uh thank you chair so yeah just to
confirm for the minute if you're
proposing the conditions will relate to
requiring the additional reserve matters
aspects
as this is a full outline also a time
limit
of two years as discussed
a condition in relation to potential
contamination on the site
um a condition relating to
um the retention of a hedge bank
it was mentioned early on by council a
lot about the foul drainage
so members may wish to see a condition
in relation to the foul drainage scheme
coming forward
at reserve matters stage so that we're
content with that
um and members may also wish to see
because of the size of the site
restricting any future development of
permitted development so that's
something that members may
wish to look at restricting future
permitted development on the site
i think that's a fair comment about
restricting permitted development
because
i think i forget who did say but when
you look at the site now in the area
it can have a modest building on there
and still have plenty of amenities space
outside
when you think some of the places that
get developed
um this has got quite a good bit of
immunity space around it but
yeah i would have no objection to
restricting permitted development rights
on its own
yeah thank you and as always um can we
uh look at delegating the wording of
that to officers
um in conjunction with the chair and
vice chair yeah happy with that
sean yeah yeah
well it's been moved and seconded to
grant this
outline permission with those conditions
that we've just discussed
um kirsty can we go to the vote please
thank you chair councillor belton at
four
councillor brown or councillor christie
or councillor craigie or
councillor leather poor
lock or councillor mcgoff
ball councillor watson oh
councillor wiseman oh that's unanimous
chair
thank you kirsty thank you everybody for
that
we'll move on then now to our final
application this morning which is
location 8 c is the borough center
centimeter road northern
and tracy tracy blackmore is going to
give the presentation of this
thank you chair so we're page 59 of the
agenda
this is a full application for the
refurbishment and alteration to the
visitors centre at the northern boroughs
country park
this application is before members due
to the land being within the ownership
of torridge district council
so this is just a location plan um as
you can see outlining in red the
location of the existing visitor center
um the red line also demonstrates the
existing vehicle and footpath access
to the building the existing building is
situated in close proximity to the beach
pebble ridge and dunes to the west as
you can see and the royal north devon
golf course to the east of the site
next slide this is just an
aerial photo i have tried to include a
red arrow i'm not sure if i have my
glasses on because it probably should be
slightly
to the left um where the visitor center
is and this sort of just shows
um again the visitors center in um on in
the location
um of the northern boroughs country park
um it should be pointed out that it is
situated with an area of outstanding
natural beauty and most of the
surrounding areas is designated as a
triple s eye
and the boroughs form an integral part
of the north devon biosphere reserve
next slide these are some photos of the
existing visitors center
as members can see the existing building
is of timber-clad finish
on a single block construction under a
slate roof slide
and there's another view of the visitor
center um as you may be able to see
there have been any sort of major
refurbishment works to the building
since its construction in 1985
the existing building is well below the
current standards in terms of energy
efficiency
and suitability for year-round usage
next slide please this is just another
view of the existing visitor center from
the footpath leading from sandy meer car
park
next slide this is just an existing
floor
plan um of the visitors center
next slide please and this is just the
existing elevations of the visitors
centre so moving on to the proposal
so this is the proposed site plan for
the refurbished visitors
center the refurbished building will
actually have a slightly smaller floor
area than the existing
as the southwest facing lobby is to be
removed
with the proposed new entrance being
within the courtyard
next slide please this is the proposed
elevation
section drawings of the refurbished
visitors building
just to guide members the proposed
external works include
the existing timber gladding cladding
being removed
and allowing for additional extra
installation
and replacing with vertical natural
timber cladding
the existing roof slates are also to be
removed and a non-reflective
dark grey metal coated sheet roof is to
be installed in its place
there are four uh roof lights to be
installed to the new northwest
roof with integral blinds to limit the
light spillage
next slide this is the proposed floor
area i mean essentially the building
will provide a sort of refurbished
enhanced exhibition space an education
meeting room
a large changing place toilet facility
up to date with sort of modern standards
and it retains a small shop and new
offices for the rangers and the workshop
so moving on to the planning
considerations of the application just
to just
quickly run through these four members
the principle of development the
existing visitors center
building is around 40 years old and the
proposed refurbishment of the building
will result in an improved facility at
the visitors centre
the refurbished building will find a
more energy efficient building and will
improve the vision appearance of the
visitors
visitor centre building the landscape
character and visual impact
the use of the vertical natural cladding
is an acceptable design
solution in this locality the proposed
roof is non-reflective and therefore
will not have any adverse effects on the
special qualities of the surrounding
sensitive landscape
the north devon aomb partnership have
been consulted on this application as
members will have seen from my report
and have welcomed the proposed changes
to the visitor centre
which they believe will enhance the
visitor experience and understanding of
the designated aomb
so drainage and flood risk is to quickly
go through these a flood water
strategy has been submitted in the
support of this application
and they recommended that the existing
foul water drainage is discharged by a
cesspool
and the surface water will be dealt with
by the existing soak aways on site
highway safety the application proposes
no challenges to the current
vehicle access arrangement on the site
and ecology
members may see following an initial
objection from natural england
detailed information was submitted in
the form of a number of documents
including visitors access management
plan and a construction management plan
subject to these documents being
conditioned of any permission
it is natural england's view that the
development is unlikely to damage or
destroy the interest features of the
triple si
um and these documents have been
conditioned as part of my recommendation
in consultation with natural england
therefore the recommendation for this
application chair is for approval
thank you tracy thank you personal lock
yeah i read through the report within
dress and i see that natural england
withdrawn their original original
objection
the aomb are in favor saying no major
impact on the landscape
and the environmental agency in the
environmental protection office got no
objections
that's on page 66 the response from the
southwest path associations
so it will improve the experience of
visitors to the center
um and i think the additional condition
seven
covers the lighting and glare concerns
that were raised
but i didn't have to laugh page 64.
second paragraph from the bottom
we note that there are high levels of
grazing in the proposed caffei building
people sitting in the cafe crazy so
i think i might be saying i think i
better say glazing that's probably my
typo
i thought they meant grazing as an
eating i think they i think it's my typo
probably eventually glazing sorry about
that
i thought they're going to allow a sheep
from the boroughs in there or something
so yes i would recommend approval
because i think it fits in the criteria
thank you thanks a lot council watson
yeah i'll second
that approval she was she's she's doing
it again stole a bit of my thunder so i
ain't got nothing else to say now
okay thanks councillor watson right
unless there's any
councillor christie if i just ask a
question
um one of the problems that was
highlighted for this
application was the actual access road
which floods
i went up there just a couple of days
ago and
can somebody explain to me why there is
a huge mobile
pumping uh engine
uh draining sandy mirror it's got a huge
pipe going into it a huge pipe going
over the pebble ridge
now this is very close this development
um are we already having to
drain the sandy mirror in order to get
to our own building or not can anyone
answer that well well i do know
cancer christie that on occasion and
we've had these high ties that have over
top the pebble bridge and the lake fills
up there it does spread onto the road
that that pump is there then just to
hurry up and clear it clear it again so
the road's clear but i think in the
planning application i
i've seen not before is at the minute
that road is to be raised slightly
when they do the new access and the
footpaths leading to the visitor center
they're all for upgrading in the overall
plan and i think that's some
yes sorry chair that's in the next
application in terms of the cafe
building yeah
thanks but yeah so that big pumps
often used once once the lake has
flooded the road
so hopefully it'll be done away with
well it's been it's been moved and
seconded to approve this one
kirsty can we go to the vote on this
please
thank you cher councillor belton uh four
councillor brown four councillor christy
oh councillor craigie or
councillor leather or councillor locke
or councillor mcgough or
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
oh that's unanimous chair thank you
christy
when we move on the next application is
8d
which again is the caffeine toilet block
with outdoor seating
then tracy you were to give this one
again i believe
yep that's right so um so i'm not going
to try and go
too much about this one because
obviously this is the same site so i'm
going to try and keep it brief as
possible
and so this is page 74 of your agenda
this is a full application for a cafe
toilet and toilet block modular building
with outdoor seating area and associated
pathways
so again the same location plan as
previous application
the proposal is to the south of the
existing business center
but again as i say exactly the same
constraints in terms of it's being
um triple si aomb and within the north
devon biosphere
next slide again this is the aerial
photo
just to locate members with the site
and as members are very familiar this is
photos of the existing visitors center
my next slide does show the proposal
is to excavate and re-contour the hill
in front of the existing business centre
to the south
to create a site for the single-story
module cafe building and outdoor seating
area next slide please
um and as you said the repairs and
upgrades are proposed to the existing
footpath vehicle access
and turning turning area of the site
moving on to the proposal um this is a
proposed block plan
just to guide members so the annotation
one
is the existing visitor center six
is the proposed new module cafe building
seven is the outdoor seating area
eight is the new tallit block and four
is the existing vehicle
access which is proposed to be
resurfaced
looks likely so this is the proposed
elevation
and section drawings of the modular
building
proposed building will measure 60 meters
by 79.2 meters
with a height of 2.75 meters
next slide please the building will be
timber club
and the roof will be dark gray shooting
flat roof
there will be external roller shutters
to the windows and solar shading to the
east and west elevation
again to avoid light spillage
next slide please this is just a
proposed floor plan which indicates the
outside decking area to be a dark
colored
composite decking board
and then the next slide this is just a
visual impression of
the proposed cafe module building
adjacent to the refurbished visitor
center
so moving on to the principle the main
planning considerations the principle of
development
cafe facility will enhance the visitor
attraction
and provide a year-round anchor to
encourage visitors and support the
economic sustainability of northern
burrows country park
landscape character and visual impact a
landscape visual impact assessment has
been used as a tool to assist in the
design process of the proposal
this has resulted in the proposed being
building being read in conjunction with
the larger and taller
adjacent visitors building the design of
materials tie in with the existing
visitor center and a single unified
building complex
drainage and flood risk again foul water
drainage actually has been supported in
support of this application
highways it is considered there is
sufficient parking provision within
northern boroughs country park
the closest being 140 metres from the
proposed cafe building
ecology again following initial
objection from natural england further
detailed information was submitted
and this has subject to sort of being
conditioned
it is natural england's view again the
development is unlikely to damage or
destroy the interest features of the
triple si
so therefore the recommendation for this
application is approval chair
thank you kirstie well
i'm happy to move this recommendation to
grant
and i noticed that designing out crime
officers a fair bit to say councillor
watson
uh if you're a if you're proposing i'll
second
okay i don't see anything wrong with
this proposal at all
it marries him very well with the
refurbishment of the visitor center yeah
and i think it'll be a very worthwhile
development when it's done right unless
anybody else wants to contribute to this
we'll go straight to the vote then it's
been recommended for approval by myself
secondly by councillor watson
kirsty if you'd like to take the vote
thank you chair councillor belton
uh four councillor brown
councillor christie councillor craigie
or councillor locke
councillor leather four councillor
mcgoff
paul councillor watson oh
councillor wiseman oh thank you that's
unanimous chair
thank you kirsty we move on then no
that's the end of the applications
agenda item nine is the appeal decisions
summary which is on pages 91-99
almost allowed there i notice
dismissed item 10 on the agenda
is costs on appeals there are no costs
awarded on appeals
item 11 is the delegated decisions
on pages
it was 100. there's just a one there the
agmb decision just the one
so then we move on to planning decisions
on 101 to 111
list of delegated planning decisions
so page 101 oh council unlock
i'm getting ready for random four right
101 then 102 103
103
104 anybody want to speak on the hundred
and foot
or cancel the lock third one for the
bottom
third one from the bottom yeah the one
from the bottom
yeah it seems to be the new phrase
as overfill accommodation because we had
this last month and
i've never seen that before when i say
it's cropped up again
yeah sean perhaps yeah overflow
accommodation not
linux yeah it seems to be the uh
the common phrase at the moment is that
those descriptions are taken off the
application form
um so it's as per the previous committee
cycle when we had a discussion
about annex and overflow so this is um
additional accommodation for the
dwelling for this single family in that
dwelling
right okay right
right page 105.
106
107
108 109
110
and 111 with the refused ones you'll
notice there
and the not permitted development one at
the bottom
right but you notice from all those
how busy the planning department are and
it's occurred to me
when we get a monthly list through
cricket there aren't half a lot of
applications
coming in at the moment right
that's the last item on the agenda
there's no part two so i'll declare the
meeting officially
closed and thank everybody and the
public who've been watching this live
streaming on youtube
i hope you found it interesting yeah um
and i'll say good morning to everybody
yeah sure